nunca
[Música]
el mandato del presidente nicolás maduro
podría ser revocado el consejo nacional
electoral venezolano aprobó solicitudes
de varios movimientos para iniciar el
trámite de un referéndum analizamos en
esta emisión
continúan las labores de limpieza tras
el derrame de petróleo en la provincia
peruana de callao tras el inusual oleaje
provocado por el tsunami que golpeó a la
isla de tonga en el pacífico sur las
autoridades cuestionan a la refinería
sobre el verdadero impacto del incidente
el gobierno de francia defendió al
ministro de educación ramis el blanqueo
envuelto en una polémica por haber
pasado de las vacaciones de año nuevo en
ibiza cuando en francia se preparaba el
protocolo sanitario escolar la oposición
pide su renuncia
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan la jornada soy
valentina torre sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos damos inicio en venezuela
el consejo nacional electoral aprobó
varias solicitudes para iniciar un
proceso de revocatoria del mandato del
presidente nicolas maduro puntualmente
las peticiones buscan que se produzca un
referendo y para que el trámite se
active se requiere conseguir el 20 por
ciento de las firmas de personas
inscritas en el registro electoral una
de las solicitudes fue presentada por el
movimiento por el revocatorio mover para
analizar esta información conectamos con
nicmer evans él es vocero de este
colectivo bienvenidos france24 cuáles
son los argumentos que tienen para pedir
que se inicie este trámite del
referéndum
mira nosotros estamos
el rechazo que existe ante en parte el
hecho 10
requerimiento ahora
para poder activar
el
camino que no está
de más y sí que va a ser
poder avanzar en el pp
una primera victoria temprana que se le
exige que reconozcan la activación del
mecanismo a partir de la solicitud hecha
por el principado
señor vamos a quienes representa el
grupo al que ustedes pertenecen
nosotros somos una agrupación de
ciudadanos que va desde los sectores
académicos sindicales gremiales
organizaciones y partidos políticos que
hemos decidido formular la propuesta de
activación del reto
en el espíritu de poder animar a que el
resto de los sectores políticos y
sociales puedan sumarse a esta
convocatoria que estamos haciendo en el
cumplimiento de la serie de activos
tenemos a gente desde las bases del
partido comunista hasta la gente de 20
venezuela de maría corina machado en una
gama de expresiones
importantes
bueno parece que estamos teniendo
problemas para conectar con nuestro
invitado así que continuamos con otras
noticias las autoridades de perú
cuestionaron las cifras entregadas por
la refinería la pampilla sobre el
verdadero impacto ambiental del derrame
de petróleo ocurrido en las playas de la
provincia de callao el oleaje producido
el sábado por la erupción volcánica y
posterior tsunami en la isla de tonga en
el pacífico sur obstaculiza la descarga
de crudo de un buque y ocasionó el
vertimiento no a pablo él lucumí nos
cuenta más
las playas de la provincia peruana de
callados se ocurrieron de petróleo la
erupción volcánica en el pacífico sur
que produjo un tsunami en la isla de
tonga y un inusual oleaje en las costas
de américa complicó el proceso de
descarga de crudo de un buque en perú y
ocasionó el derrame según informó la
refinería la pampilla
las autoridades ambientales peruanas
informaron que los siete galones de
petróleo que según la refinería fueron
vertidos al mar no coinciden con la
cantidad que han sacado del océano el
ministerio de ambiente ha desplegado una
brigada para que atienda a la fauna
afectada y evalúe los daños
se evaluó playas costa azul y valla
blanca y se procedió al cierre esperamos
que las investigaciones den con los
responsables y sean sancionados al
momento del derrame la refinería colocó
barreras de contención de hasta 500
metros de longitud pero la marea sigue
contaminada con la sustancia
habitantes de la zona y defensores del
medio ambiente piden que se lleve a la
justicia a los responsables al ministro
de ambiente que por favor lo haga
seguimiento y que los responsables
tengan una canción porque esto afecta a
los pescadores a la población que nos
alimentamos de la pesca y a los animales
marinos ya nuestra fauna marina el
tsunami en la isla de tonga también
ocasionó oleaje inusual en la playa en
la región lambayeque que cubre la vida
de dos personas el domingo la primera
ministra mirtha vásquez pidió a la
marina que dé explicaciones por la
alerta tardía de tsunami el presidente
de paraguay mario abdo benítez dio
positivo por kobe 19 y presenta síntomas
leves a través de 'twitter' el
ministerio de salud informó que el
mandatario seguirá en aislamiento
preventivo en el que se encuentra desde
el pasado domingo día en que su esposa
silvana abdo dio positivo actualmente
paraguay enfrenta a su tercera ola de
coronavirus tras el aumento consecutivo
de casos durante las últimas semanas
en francia los sindicatos de profesores
convocaron a una nueva jornada de
movilizaciones este jueves al tiempo que
se suman más voces a pedir la renuncia
del ministro de educación ramis el
blanqueo tras el escándalo desatado de
luego de conocerse que anunció desde
ibiza el protocolo contra el hobbit 19
para el sector educativo el portavoz del
gobierno gabriela tal defendió al
funcionario y dijo que cumplió con las
normas del gabinete que estipulan que en
vacaciones deben quedarse en europa a
menos de dos horas de parís estar
localizables y con capacidad para seguir
trabajando
jean-michel blanca se enfrenta a un
complicado regreso al trabajo tras las
vacaciones de navidad este martes el
medio de investigación mediapart reveló
que el ministro de educación de francia
estaba de vacaciones en ibiza mientras
daba a conocer el protocolo cobit de
vuelta a las aulas el día antes de que
las clases empezarán y a través de una
entrevista en el país jiang un medio de
pago las críticas han llegado desde todo
el abanico de la oposición
vuelvo a pedir que jean michel blanca
renunció el problema no es ibiza es la
inexperiencia de este ministro el
ministro sin embargo blanco cuenta con
el apoyo del gobierno del primer
ministro jan castex quien defiende que
los anuncios de último minuto no tienen
que ver con las vacaciones y que la
polémica es puro electoralismo de cara a
las presidenciales
blanquer ha estado muy presente estuvo
en la reunión de gobierno del 27 de
diciembre se tomó unos días de
vacaciones mientras esperábamos las
recomendaciones del consejo científico
por eso el protocolo largo de cádiz
este argumento no convence a los
sindicatos de profesores franceses que
han convocado una nueva jornada de
huelga este jueves la comunidad
educativa ya salió a las calles la
semana pasada en protesta por los
cambios constantes de protocolos
sanitarios por la falta de personal
suplente y las carencias de material de
bioseguridad la nueva controversia
intensifica las tensiones y hace entrar
la inversión social y educativa en el
caldeado debate de las presidenciales de
abril el primer ministro británico boris
johnson negó haberle mentido al
parlamento hace una semana sobre la
fiesta que realizó en mayo de 2020 en su
residencia oficial cuando el país se
encontraba en pleno confinamiento por la
pandemia
johnson aseguró que nadie le advirtió
que el evento iba en contra de las
restricciones pero previamente dominique
coming su antigua mano derecha he
indicado que tanto él como otro
funcionario alertaron por escrito que
debía cancelar la fiesta
nadie me dijo que lo que estábamos
haciendo era como dice contra la regla
1020 sting uds son que el evento en
cuestión no era un evento de trabajo y
como dije en la cámara de los comunes
cuando salí a ese jardín pensé que
estaba asistiendo a un evento de trabajo
dyn
en otras noticias en un nuevo intento
por desescalar la atención entre
occidente y rusia ante una posible
invasión a ucrania el viernes se
reunirán en ginebra suiza el secretario
de estado de eeuu anthony blinken y su
homólogo ruso el canciller sérguei
lávrov en la llamada telefónica de este
martes que sostuvieron los funcionarios
blink en reiteró a la breve el
compromiso de washington con la
soberanía de ucrania y subrayó que
cualquier discusión sobre la seguridad
en europa debe incluir a la otan y a los
aliados europeos
y la multinacional estadounidense
microsoft anunció la compra por 68 mil
700 millones de dólares de la empresa de
videojuegos activision blizzard una de
las mayores desarrolladoras de
videojuegos del mundo responsable de
productos como candy cross o call of
duty de acuerdo con microsoft esta
adquisición que es la mayor en su
historia la convierte en la tercera
mayor compañía del sector de los
videojuegos está previsto que la
operación se complete este año una vez
recibida la aprobación de los
reguladores
en la materia
esto es todo por el momento en france 24
pero los invitamos a visitar nuestra
página web france24 puntocom para
ampliar todas las noticias y repetir
este y otros programas feliz tarde para
todos
[Música]